One approach that was taken to solve
the problem with the 17 instructions,
was to rewrite the binary
of the guest VM so
that it never really issues
any one of these operations.
This process is called
binary translation.
This approach was pioneered by
research at Stanford University,
by a group led by
Professor Mendel Rosenblum.
And subsequently,
this was commercialized as VMware.
Now some 15 plus years and 30,
$40 billion later, VMware still
owns by far the largest share of the
virtualized cores in the server market.
Rosenblum later received
the ACM Fellow reward, and
in the recognition he was specifically
credited for reinventing virtualization.
He served as VMware's chief
scientist for about ten years and
now is back full time at Stanford.
Let me give you now a brief description
of what binary translation actually is.
A key thing to note is that the goal
that's pursued by VMware is to run
unmodified guest operating systems.
Meaning that we don't need to
install any special drivers,
or policies or otherwise to change
the guest OS in order to run
in a virtualized environment.
As a startup, they clearly couldn't
tell Microsoft to modify Windows so
that VMware can improve it's,
it's success rate.
So, this type of virtualization
where the guest OS is not modified
is called full virtualization.
The basic approach
consists of the following.
Instruction sequences that are about
to be executed are dynamically
captured from the VM binary,
and this is typically done at
some meaningful granularity like a basic
block such as a loop or a function.
Now the reason that this is done
dynamically versus statically,
so up front before any code is actually
run, is because the exact execution
sequence may depend on the parameters
that are available at runtime.
So it's input dependent.
So you cannot really do all of this in
an efficient way statically up front.
Or in some cases you just cannot do it
all because you don't have the input
parameters.
So then you dynamically capture these
code blocks and then inspect them to see
whether any of these 17 infamous
instructions is about to be issued.
If it turns out that the code
block doesn't have any of
these bad instructions,
it's marked as save and
allowed to execute natively
at hardware speeds.
However, if one of the bad instructions
is found in the code block,
then that particular instruction
is translated into some other
instruction sequence that avoids
the undesired instruction and
in some way,
emulates the desired behavior.
This can possibly be achieved, even by
bypassing a trap to the hypervisor.
Certainly, binary translation
adds overheads, and
the number of mechanisms are
incorporated specifically in the viewer
solutions, in order to improve
the efficiency of the process.
These things include mechanisms such as,
caching code fragments that correspond
to the translated basic blocks.
So that the translation process
can be avoided in the future.
Also, the steps like
distinguishing which portions of
the binary should be analyzed.
For instance, distinguishing between
the kernel and the application code and
making sure that the kernel code
is the one that's analyzed and
various other optimizations.